Penyelesai nilai eigen kuantum variasi atau VQE ialah salah satu algoritma hibrid kuantum-klasik terawal dan ia
menarik atas beberapa sebab. Pertama, seperti yang akan kita lihat dalam video ini, ia adalah pendekatan yang menjanjikan untuk beberapa jenis masalah. Kedua, ia penting
dari sudut sejarah dan telah membuka jalan untuk banyak algoritma yang ditingkatkan seperti adapt VQE.
Dan akhirnya, VQE agak mudah. Senang nak faham apa yang komputer kuantum dan klasik buat dalam algoritma ini
dan cara mereka berinteraksi. Ada empat komponen utama pengiraan VQE.
Pertama, ada operator, sering Hamiltonian, yang kita panggil H, yang menggambarkan sifat sistem yang
kau nak optimumkan. Cara lain untuk kata ini ialah kau mencari vektor eigen operator ini yang
sepadan dengan nilai eigen minimum. Kita sering panggil vektor eigen tu keadaan asas.
Seterusnya, ada ansatz yang perkataan Jermannya bermaksud pendekatan. Ini ialah circuit kuantum yang menyediakan keadaan kuantum yang menganggar
vektor eigen yang kau cari. Sebenarnya, ansatz ialah keluarga circuit kuantum sebab beberapa gate dalam
ansatz diparameterkan. Iaitu, ia disuap dengan parameter yang boleh kita ubah. Keluarga circuit kuantum ini
boleh menyediakan keluarga keadaan kuantum yang menganggar keadaan asas.
Seterusnya, kita perlukan anggaran, iaitu cara menganggar nilai jangkaan operator H ke atas keadaan kuantum variasi semasa.
Kadang-kadang yang betul-betul kita ambil berat ialah nilai jangkaan ini sahaja, yang kita
panggil fungsi kos. Kali lain kita ambil berat tentang fungsi yang lebih rumit yang masih boleh ditulis bermula dari
satu atau lebih nilai jangkaan.
Akhirnya, kita perlukan pengoptimum klasik, iaitu algoritma yang mengubah parameter untuk cuba minimumkan fungsi kos ini.
Jom gariskan masalah yang nak kita selesaikan dan pendekatan umum sebelum bahas cara kuantum memainkan peranan. Kita
boleh bentukkan banyak masalah pengoptimuman yang kritikal untuk sains dan industri sebagai masalah nilai matriks. Biasanya, kau
nak nilai eigen minimum matriks kau dan vektor eigen yang sepadan dengannya. Matriks H boleh jadi
Hamiltonian yang menggambarkan tenaga sistem fizikal. Dan nilai eigen minimum ialah tenaga keadaan asas
E0 dan vektor eigen ialah keadaan asas kuantum yang sepadan yang sering dilambangkan SI sub0.
Atau matriks boleh menggambarkan fungsi kos yang rumit berkaitan masalah pengoptimuman kombinatorial
seperti dalam logistik dan keadaan eigen s subopt ialah penyelesaian optimum
masalah seperti rentetan binari yang melabel potongan dalam graf rangkaian pengedaran. Dalam amalan ia
biasa mendengar istilah Hamiltonian digunakan untuk semua matriks yang menarik walaupun di luar sains fizikal. Katakan
kita berminat dengan matriks n baris dan n lajur. Masalah sedemikian boleh diselesaikan dengan cepat dan tepat menggunakan
penyelesai klasik untuk n sehingga beberapa ratus atau ribu tanpa sebarang andaian dibuat tentang matriks. Untuk matriks
jarang, yang kebanyakannya sifar sebagai entri, ini boleh lebih besar dengan n setinggi satu bilion walaupun pada laptop.
Tapi untuk masalah yang benar-benar besar yang melebihi nombor ini, kaedah anggaran atau heuristik sering diperlukan.
Semakin besar matriks dan semakin kurang jarang, semakin susah masalah dan semakin banyak helah bijak yang mesti digunakan. Andaikan matriks kau
sangat besar sehingga pengedaran tepat bukan satu pilihan. Andaikan lagi bahawa kau tahu cukup tentang masalah kau sehingga kau boleh
buat beberapa tekaan tentang struktur keseluruhan keadaan sasaran dan kau nak cungkil keadaan yang serupa dengan
tekaan awal kau untuk tengok sama ada kos atau tenaga kau boleh dikurangkan lagi. Ini ialah pendekatan variasi dan ia adalah satu kaedah
yang digunakan bila pengedaran tepat bukan pilihan menggunakan komputer klasik. Ini akan berfungsi seperti berikut.
Pertama, kau buat keadaan tekaan dengan beberapa parameter theta yang akan kau ubah.
Walaupun tekaan awal ini boleh rawak, itu tidak digalakkan. Kita nak guna pengetahuan tentang masalah yang ada
untuk sesuaikan tekaan kita sebanyak mungkin.
Kedua, kita akan kira nilai jangkaan operator dengan sistem dalam keadaan tu.
Ketiga, kita akan ubah parameter variasi dan ulangi.
Keempat, kita akan guna maklumat yang terkumpul tentang landskap keadaan yang mungkin dalam subruang variasi kau untuk buat tekaan yang semakin baik
dan mendekati keadaan sasaran.
Prinsip variasi menjamin keadaan variasi kita tak boleh hasilkan nilai eigen yang lebih rendah daripada
keadaan asas sasaran. Jadi semakin rendah nilai jangkaan, semakin baik anggaran keadaan asas kita. Jom
bincangkan kesukaran setiap langkah dalam pendekatan ini.
Menetapkan atau mengemaskini parameter mudah secara pengiraan. Kesukaran di sana ialah dalam memilih parameter awal yang berguna secara fizikal
yang bermotivasi. Menggunakan maklumat terkumpul daripada lelaran sebelumnya untuk kemaskini parameter sedemikian
sehingga kau mendekati keadaan asas adalah tidak trivial. Tapi algoritma pengoptimuman klasik wujud yang
melakukan ini dengan agak cekap. Pengoptimuman klasik ini hanya mahal sebab ia mungkin memerlukan banyak
lelaran. Dalam kes terburuk, bilangan lelaran mungkin berskala secara eksponen dengan n.
Langkah tunggal yang paling mahal secara pengiraan hampir pasti ialah nilai jangkaan matriks kau menggunakan
keadaan tertentu. Matriks n kali n mesti bertindak pada vektor n elemen yang sepadan dengan tertib n kuasa dua
operasi pendaraban dalam kes terburuk. Ini mesti dilakukan pada setiap lelaran parameter. Untuk matriks yang sangat besar,
ini mempunyai kos pengiraan yang tinggi. Sekarang bayangkan serahkan bahagian pengiraan ini
kepada komputer kuantum. Daripada mengira nilai jangkaan ini, kau anggarkannnya dengan menyediakan
keadaan s theta pada komputer kuantum menggunakan ansatz variasi kau dan kemudian buat pengukuran.
Jom urai itu sedikit. H umumnya tidak mudah diukur. Contohnya, ia boleh terdiri daripada banyak
operator Pauli x y dan z yang tidak bertukar.
Tapi H boleh ditulis sebagai gabungan linear sebutan H subalpha yang setiap satunya mudah diukur. Contohnya,
operator Pauli atau kumpulan operator Pauli yang bertukar secara bitwise. Nilai
jangkaan H ke atas keadaan S ialah jumlah berwajaran nilai jangkaan sebutan konstituen H alpha.
WEBVTT
Ungkapan ini berlaku untuk mana-mana keadaan s tapi kita akan menggunakannya khusus dengan keadaan variasi s theta.
Setiap sebutan h alfa boleh diukur m kali menghasilkan sampel pengukuran s sub-alfa j dengan j berjalan dari
1 hingga m dan memulangkan nilai jangkaan dan sisihan piawai. Kita boleh jumlahkan
sebutan-sebutan ini dan merebakkan ralat melalui jumlah.
Ini tidak memerlukan pendaraban berskala besar atau sebarang proses yang semestinya berskala seperti n kuasa dua. Sebaliknya ia
memerlukan beberapa pengukuran pada komputer quantum. Kalau korang tidak memerlukan terlalu banyak daripada itu pendekatan ini boleh menjadi
cekap. Dan itulah bahagian quantum VQE. Tapi jom bincangkan sebab kenapa ini mungkin tidak cekap. Satu sebab
bagi banyak pengukuran adalah untuk mengurangkan ketidakpastian statistik dalam anggaran korang untuk pengiraan ketepatan yang sangat tinggi.
Sebab lain adalah bilangan rentetan Pauli yang diperlukan untuk merentangkan keseluruhan matriks korang. Kerana matriks Pauli tambah
identiti merentangkan ruang semua operator dimensi tertentu kita dijamin
bahawa kita boleh menulis matriks yang diminati sebagai jumlah berwajaran operator Pauli seperti yang kita lakukan sebelumnya. Di sini C alfa adalah
pekali berangka dan H alfa adalah rentetan operator Pauli yang bertindak pada semua Qubit yang menggambarkan sistem korang.
H alfa akan berbentuk seperti ini di mana operator Pauli ke-n dari kanan bertindak pada Qubit ke-n. Jadi kita boleh
ukur operator kita dengan mengukur siri operator Pauli. Tapi kita tidak boleh ukur semua operator Pauli itu
secara serentak. Operator Pauli tidak termasuk identiti tidak bertukar ganti antara satu sama lain kalau ia
dikaitkan dengan Qubit yang sama. Contohnya kita boleh ukur I Z IIZ dan ZZ
XZ secara serentak kerana kita boleh ukur I dan Z secara serentak untuk Qubit
ketiga. Dan kita boleh tahu I dan X secara serentak untuk Qubit pertama. Tapi kita tidak boleh
ukur semua Z dan Z zz ZX secara serentak kerana Z dan X tidak
bertukar ganti dan kedua-duanya bertindak pada Qubit ke sifar.
Jadi kita uraikan matriks H kita kepada jumlah Pauli yang bertindak pada Qubit berbeza.
Sesetengah elemen jumlah itu boleh diukur sekaligus. Kita panggil ini kumpulan Pauli yang bertukar ganti. Bergantung pada
berapa banyak sebutan tidak bertukar ganti yang ada kita mungkin perlukan banyak kumpulan sedemikian. Panggil bilangan kumpulan Pauli bertukar ganti itu.
sebagai ngcp.
Kalau ngcp adalah kecil ini boleh berfungsi dengan baik.
Kalau h mempunyai jutaan kumpulan ini tidak akan berguna. Korang rekod nilai jangkaan atau fungsi kos
untuk set parameter theta yang digunakan dalam keadaan korang dan kemudian korang kemaskini parameter dari masa ke semasa. Korang boleh guna
nilai jangkaan atau nilai fungsi kos yang korang anggarkan untuk menghampiri kecerunan fungsi kos korang dalam
subruang keadaan yang disampel oleh ansatz korang.
Kedua-dua pengoptimum klasikal berasaskan kecerunan dan bebas kecerunan wujud. kedua-duanya mengalami isu kebolehlatihan yang berpotensi seperti
pelbagai minimum tempatan dan kawasan besar ruang parameter dengan kecerunan hampir sifar yang dipanggil platau steril.
Jadi adakah VQE akan menyelesaikan semua masalah tersukar korang? Tidak. Tapi lebih baik dalam semua pengiraan tidak pernah menjadi tujuannya. Kita dah
mengubah apa yang menentukan kos pengiraan. Tengok apa yang kita dah pertukarkan. Kita dah beralih daripada proses
yang kerumitannya bergantung hanya pada dimensi matriks kepada satu yang bergantung pada ketepatan yang diperlukan dan bilangan
operator Pauli tidak bertukar ganti yang membentuk matriks. Bahagian terakhir tidak mempunyai analog dalam pengiraan klasikal.
Berdasarkan kebergantungan baru ini untuk matriks jarang atau matriks yang melibatkan sedikit rentetan Pauli tidak bertukar ganti proses
ini mungkin berguna. Inilah kes untuk sistem spin yang berinteraksi. Contohnya untuk matriks padat ia mungkin
kurang berguna. Kita tahu misalnya bahawa sistem kimia sering mempunyai Hamiltonian yang melibatkan ratusan ribu bahkan
jutaan rentetan Pauli. Ada kerja yang menarik dilakukan untuk mengurangkan bilangan sebutan ini tapi
sistem kimia mungkin lebih sesuai untuk beberapa algoritma lain yang akan kita bincangkan dalam kursus ini.
Penggunaan VQE yang berkesan juga memerlukan kita tahu atribut keadaan sasaran kita dan boleh memilih keadaan awal yang didorong secara fizikal yang baik
serta ansatz yang baik dengan parameter variasi yang agak sedikit. Ini boleh menjadi
cukup mencabar. VQE menunjukkan bagaimana kekuatan komputer klasikal dan quantum boleh digabungkan
tanpa menambah kaedah yang lebih baru. VQE tidak membantu kita menyelesaikan masalah yang tidak tertakluk kepada komputer klasikal tapi
ia terus memainkan peranan dalam pembangunan algoritma. Dan VQE juga mengajar kita bahawa memindahkan langkah dari komputer klasikal
ke komputer quantum bukanlah lebih baik atau lebih buruk untuk semua tujuan. Sebaliknya ia
mengubah faktor-faktor yang menentukan kecekapan algoritma korang. Ini adalah pelajaran umum yang penting dalam pengiraan
hibrid klasikal-quantum.